In order to establish connections
with investors you have to network.
The question is, where do you start?
And you can start by going to events and
meeting people there,
you can start through your own personal
network that's already in place, but
the key thing is you have
to establish that network.
And there are various tools you
can use to help with that, but
there's no way around it.
Investors are receiving pitches and
business plans from people all the time.
And what they're really going to
end up paying attention to
is something whether some personal
connection with the idea.
There's a personal connection
with whoever the founder is and
that's what you need